so you'll go from just an idea of like
looking in the mirror seeing lipstick
and be like okay yeah there's a song I
Gotta make yeah oh well speaking of
instead of doing 20 50 songs I actually
have a spreadsheet where I wrote down 50
Concepts oh between 50 and 80 Concepts
so it'll be like a spreadsheet of like
ideas like that yeah you'd be like you
know what I feel like I can go somewhere
with this yeah like oh the you know she
kissed me on my neck lipstick prince I
gotta write about that but you know I
would just things that happened at the
party I like the way that I saw him look
at her you know that's that's a line
like I'm just going watching everything
and you know as Nina Simone would say an
artist's job is to reflect the times and
a time was had the time was had it was I
mean you've learned from the best yeah
Prince and puffy what are we talking
about okay we talk about Grace Jones
though let's talk about the women okay
Grace Jones is on this project yeah I
mean she taught me so much you know even
as I'm on my own journey of honoring all
of me
um you know she's done a lot of what
I've already done in her own way and so
it's just great to have her in the
studio I spent 72 hours with her wow and
she recorded a lot of stuff and so you
have her on there speaking French you
have Nia Long I was going to ask the Nia
Long that's on the album is the Nia Long
Nia Long oh Nia Long the one and the
only need along yeah she came over and
recorded and she always like she's
amazing yeah I mean obviously shout out
to Friday you know yeah exactly that
helped and and uh boys in the hood I
mean she's yeah she's one of them she
has icons when you're growing up yeah
yeah it's a 80s baby
he alone was one of the leaders yeah
like Nia alley for me too that's how I
knew I was like oh I'm definitely queer
yeah Nia Long is my girlfriend did Nia
long was she the one who made you
realize you were attracted to women
definitely she's the first I don't know
maybe not the first but
she confirmed it so Nia Long confirmed I
could get down with chicks for sure for
me yeah when I saw her I was like but
then I didn't know if I wanted to be her
or be with her she's one of those people
where you look at her and you're like I
want to be just like that and obviously
I am inspired by her Which movie was it
that you saw her in that made you be
like Jesus uh boys in the hood
um
and then Love Jones for sure I mean come
on yeah you know but I'm so happy to
have her as a friend and
um you know like a big sister and you
know even went down to when I was
releasing my press photos before I
released them she you know I let her see
them and she was like oh you should you
should release that like this is the one
you coming out the water like this is it
so there were a lot of wonderful women
um from dochi to Amore to Grace to Nia
to Sister Nancy which is dope I was
gonna say it's also dope to see sister
Nancy because obviously sister Nancy's a
oh g g o g in the reggae world like
man like what is that like how do you
get a hold of sister Nancy I just
reached out like who do you reach out to
who do we
I just had my I said somebody on my team
who knew her nephew right and then we
got in touch with her and when I got on
the phone with her she she knew a lot
about me and I was like what I love you
and I just her story is so cool you know
her during the time that she came up
reggae DJs were not
for what women reggae DJ specifically
women who DJ'd during that era were not
really accepted you know they were told
her family told her to go do this you
need to be doing this and she was like
no this is what I'm gonna do and now you
can't go to a house party or a regular
party in general without playing bomba I
was going to say she's one of and also
like one of the most sampled songs ever
ever yeah you can and so to get her to
do some original stuff right it was just
like
just a dream come true you know
incredible and so yeah